as far as science was concerned I was
completely clay hopeless I mean I
remember in the but my biology I was put
in the front row hated being in the
front row because you know you weren't
direct contact with the person who's
teaching you and I would have an ear
phone in my house have one these first
transistors because I burial two
transistors sort came out when I was
young
Rett radio and it was smallish and I
hadn't the air phone and I was listening
to the tennis those you're not paying
attention in class not a talk but I was
doing very badly but but there prep
school I I discovered a a meteorite as I
was walking back from the games sadly I
didn't put it in my pocket was quite
large I was an honest I gave it to the
headmaster and it was sort of I don't
know where he went to into a museum or
something but I wish I can kindly it is
just so you can relive the moment when
you discovered a meteorite in the
flowerbed of your prep school many moons
ago I have a meteorite that you can
touch but you're not but you only I'm
not going to hand it to you because I
don't know what you gonna do with it
I'll be very careful about they're very
respectful this is four and a half
billion years old what whoa whoa now
what why I'm amazed by this is this a
part of me yes it yeah this part that
he's good clever man here you hide the
right guy for you moving the this is
part of a meteorite that was the size of
that sphere of the Hayden sphere I am
most of which vaporized on it on impact
with earth fragments got strewn around
and the crater that was made by the
parent of this is still around and you
can find it in Arizona and it's called
meteor crater have you analyzed this is
mostly iron about ninety percent iron
ten percent nickel a common in the kind
of meteorite that this is I here's
something to think about if you once you
feel that imagine that just falling from
the ceiling and hitting you in the head
then your head is a pile of goo right
now imagine something the size of that
sphere and it's gonna make a crater a
mile across
now imagine something the size of Mount
Everest moving at 10 miles per second
and you can judge
how devastating that could be to our
ecosystem did it affect the tilt no on
that level it's like a gnats lying into
the buttocks of an elephant we had some
elephants in our movie one walked off
set actually probably not in the box